[Music]
Antonio Brown this story breaking just
before we stepped into the podcast
studio on Tuesday the Steelers wide
receiver coming off his best game of the
season now facing a little adversity to
lawsuits coming at him from an April
incident in which Brown allegedly yelled
at security all right that's that's
pretty normal but also through items
from inside in a South Florida apartment
off of a balcony
both lawsuits are for damages in excess
of 15,000 and the lawsuit alleges and
it's from a guardian of a two-year-old
boy that brown you know intentionally
inflicted emotional distress and assault
because the furniture and everything
that he threw off the balcony almost hit
the kid and it was very upsetting for
the child and that was yelling at the
security was that like a that came after
him throwing this stuff off the balcony
like was security came up and he yelled
at them and that's part of the lawsuit
that totally that's a separate that's a
separate loss all right let me address
the balcony thing first of all my guess
is Antonio Brown just read that story
about the two-year-old shredding the
money saw two-year-old down there and
said maybe that's him and tried to hit
him with some potted plants and some
patio furniture that's a guess that
maybe I'm wrong but that sounds like
something that could easily be possible
something I would have done and I have
actually twice in my life
gotten in trouble for throwing things
off of balconies on both times it was
out of sheer drunken perversity well
what did he throw I this sounds right I
can remember one freshman year it's all
been chairs it's all been share related
freshman year I threw two wooden kitchen
chairs out of the eight story window I
should know six story window of my dorms
kitchen Monroe sharp you're in Monroe no
you weren't Irby Monroe I was in two
sharp and threw two chairs out and I
remember we had to go in and have a
meeting with with like the people in
charge of like authority at Tulane and
they were like they were like trying so
not to laugh and they were like you know
you guys threw him out right where the
walkway is and it in a chair leg through
the heads not gonna help anybody during
finals and then I just lost it right in
the face
well it's true I mean what if Antonia
Brown and hit the kid by the way or what
if you had hit someone with the
furniture only in college can you get
away with that it's like we're cashing
your checks so we're just not gonna say
oh we're lucky if someone got in hit I
would I'm gone from school
it was like the first three months of
college I'm gone and I'm doing some jail
time the second time was plastic patio
furniture and Martha's Vineyard I came
home from work and this guy we were
living in some poor guy's house who was
like it was an expensive house but he
was getting putting the finishing
touches on it so we get to living with
you yes we got to live that cheap for a
month oh yeah and and I got home and he
just put out like all brand-new plastic
patio furniture and I thought it's
indestructible and I you know was
picking it up and throwing it off the
balcony and a lot of it broke and so
since he couldn't match it he had to buy
like a whole set it cost me I think a
week's paycheck from the seafood shanty
to pay for all that furniture but I do
remember the line I walked downstairs
hungover and every all my roommates are
like nervous and alone yeah like eight
people in a four bedroom there
everyone's nervous looking at me and the
landlord goes Anthony what happened to
my chairs
and everyone thinks I'm about to put up
a fight or like deny it or something I
just look and I go gravity's a bitch man
he laughed everybody laughed
I bought him some new chairs everybody
was okay I think that I think this is a
cool story I think it's cool van Tonio
brown to throw things at two-year-olds
what do you think what's your take I
think you were one of the worst
employees the seafood shanty has ever
seen cutting up those seafood and yeah I
think you're cutting up those you know
what I'm saying cutting up the clams you
were in the cold bar or putting up your
like a low wattage job trying to keep
you kind of out of you know anywhere
that you could mess things up too poorly
I'm amazed they don't rob our cell of
that of that operation I was the
mitochondria I'm amazed I don't remember
you throwing this stuff off off the
balcony but yeah I think Antonio Browns
pretty lucky if it had hit I mean it
seems a little crazy that you can get
$20,000 off of Antonio Brown because he
scared the kid is that like a law like I
would think either it hits the kid and
you can get who knows how much or it
missed the kid and you're you're out of
luck
a shrapnel from the pot hits the kid
that wouldn't happen instead it was just
emotional it was emotional distress I
think that he doesn't hit the kid he
shouldn't get any credit we're taping
this every week on Tuesday night just
one night ago history was made in the
New Orleans Superdome a place that where
we've had some good times over the years
when Drew Brees set the all-time leading
passer last night last night yeah we
weren't there last thing I'm saying
we've had some good times at the
Superdome
sure Tulane games Sugar Bowl it's about
it some Saints games I know I went to a
bunch of Saints games but last night was
kind of just a big party thrown for Drew
Brees
it almost felt like the Redskins let
Drew Brees set this record but before it
all happened to fans of Drew Brees
walked seventy one thousand nine hundred
and forty yards around New Orleans to
symbolize how many passing yards he has
thrown in his career so that equates to
about 41 miles and they started at 3 in
the morning and they ended up at the
Superdome and they ended up getting to
meet drew Brees before the game yeah it
sounded a cook a cool story because they
got very New Orleans thing to do like
let's start at 3 in the morning well
walk all over the city get to the game
just in time and we'll be great and I
was like assumed they would of course be
drinking like it's a bar crawl but this
is like their job and they were
professional and they just walked with
like water and like band-aids in case
they got blisters
I'm thumbs down on this one but I am
excited I'm my favorite thing about Drew
Brees setting the record two things one
is the flag they got they got hit with a
penalty after the touchdown for taunting
not for excessive celebration but still
you think he picked that one up
secondly the the that they don't get my
trophy they give him a laminated
certificate
yeah the official the the official of
the game got this laminated you know
piece of paper like a menu like it was a
third grader who just got Best
sportsmanship yeah they give the press
pass and kick competition for his soccer
team and handed it to Drew Brees in the
middle of the field it was one of the
most insane things and they did like a
little close-up of the picture and it
was just like Drew Brees most passing
yards
in history yeah they handed that to him
I I really enjoy it have been better if
they've given him a box of dude wipes
[Music]
you